they staked around the castle walls from
the early hours
thousands waited to see their prince now
King on his first visit to Wales we got
up very early this morning but Jaden
obviously didn't sleep all night because
he was so excited to see the king so
we've been up quite early and we
traveled down by train uh Jaden what is
it that you're so excited about I'm
really excited to shape the king's hand
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
along with the queen and king I just
wanted them to remember a historic
moment you know when our new king as
coming to Wales we're not able to get to
London to pay our respects for the for
the Queen's passing so I just wanted
them to have something that they could
remember
while the queue grew longer two miles
away the king and queen consort began
their day at landaf Cathedral for a
service of remembrance
the king signed the visitor book this
time bringing his own pen after leaky
ink issues earlier in the week
the pair then met local school children
before heading on to the Senate
condolences from the Welsh Parliament
before addressing it in their own
language
it must surely be counted the greatest
privilege to belong to a land that could
Inspire such devotion
I am resolved to honor that selfish
example in the spirit of the words
by which I have always tried to live my
own life I serve
for politics to the people the Royals
made their way to the waiting crowds
inside Cardiff Castle
[Applause]
meetings with dignitaries and the first
Minister even time for a much needed
pick-me-up
but it wasn't long before the wait was
over for those outside many finally
getting to shake the new King's hand it
was amazing yeah we've been here since
about eight o'clock this morning
they learn it was amazing my three
grandchildren and my two daughters and
yeah it was really special did you get
to shake yes yes and the queen came
along as well that was important it was
nice for him to have a memory of it
because I remember the queen when I was
little missing the queen and so forth
for him to meet the king and his history
isn't it
but not all were happy
why not all support the monarchy here in
Wales thousands have turned out to greet
the new king and the queen consort in
what's being described as a day of
transition for this country
the next generation will grow up with
King Charles
the former Prince of this nation now
starting a new journey in his
relationship with Wales
down what is Sky News in Cardiff